[موسيقى]
سلاح روسي يفقد صواريخ كيف قدراتها
واوروبا تقولها صراحه اوكرانيا لن تتمكن
من هزيمه روسيا كوريا الشماليه تعلنها على
امريكا ان تعتاد على الوضع الجديد قمه
العرب والمسلمين تخرج ببيان ختامي وتل
ابيب تطالب العرب التحرك الفوري الجيش
العبري يطالب باخلاء مستشفى الشفاء
وواشنطن لا تستطيع تاكيد ادعاء الكيان
الفصائل تستخدم استراتيجيه الانفاق
الوهميه مظاهره هي الاكبر من نوعها منذ
الحرب على العراق في لندن بعد هدوء لشهرين
الصواريخ الروسيه تمطر العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف جو بايدن يخطط لحديث صارم مع نظيره
الصيني شيجين بينغ وترامب يضع خطه لانهاء
الحرب لا جديد في القمه الوضع قاسم جدا
والعرب يجتمعون ومعهم الدول الاسلاميه
ايضا لبحث التطورات في القطاع وبحسب
رويترز فقد خرج البيان الختامي للقمه
العربيه الاسلاميه المشتركه ليدعو لوقف
تصدير الاسلحه والذخائر الى تل ابيب والى
كسر الحصار على القطاع وادخال قوافل
مساعدات انسانيه عربيه واسلاميه ودوليه
لكن الى من تم توجيه هذه المطالب يا ترى
فيما قال الرئيس السوري الاسد ان الفصائل
فرضت واقعا جديدا في منطقتنا ومكنت من
تغيير المعادلات مضيفا اذا لم نمتلك ادوات
حقيقيه للضغط فلا معنا لاي خطوه نقوم بها
او خطاب نلقيه تجاه القطاع ليعترف الجيش
العبري بسقوط عشره من جنوده في كمين محكم
للفصائل في بيت حانون تمثل في تفخيخ انفاق
وهميه ثم استدراج جنود الكيان اليها من
جهته اكد امين عام مقامه لبنان ان من
يستطيع ان يوقف الهجوم على القطاع ومن
يدير هذا الهجوم اي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في المقابل طالب المتحدث باسم
مكتب نتنياهو اوفر جندلمان القاده العرب
بالتحرك الفوري لتحرير 200 اسير لدى
الفصائل اما على الارض فذكرت صحيفه هي
ارتس ان الجيش العبري طالب مدير مستشفى
الشفاء في القطاع بضروره اجلاء جميع
المرضى كون المستشفى يقع في منطقه
اشتباكات لكن مصادر في الكونجرس اكدت
لشبكه ام بي سي ان واشنطن لا تستط يع
تاكيد الدعاء تلبيب بشان وجود مقر للفصائل
تحت مستشفى الشفاء لدى الكيان قالت صحيفه
يدعوت احرنوت العبريه ان المئات تظاهروا
امام منزل نتنياهو في مدينه قيساريا جنوب
حيفا مطالبين باستقالته فيما تظاهر الاف
العبريين في تل ابيب فيما يعرف بساحه
المختطفين للمطالبه باطلاق سراح الاسرى
لدى الفصائل في القطاع ليشكك المحلل
الاسرائيلي ناحوم برنياع في امكانيه تحقيق
النصر في القطاع مؤكدا ان النت ياهو يحاول
التسويق لانتصار غير موجود بحسب يد عوت
احرونوت العبريه في بريطانيا لا يتوقف
البريطانيون عن ابداء رايهم في هذه الحرب
حيث خرجت مظاهره حاشده في لندن هي الاكبر
من نوعها منذ المظاهرات المعارضه للحرب
على العراق وذلك لاظهار الدعم للمدنيين
والدعوه لوقف القصف العبري على القطاع
والرفع الفوري للحصار وخرج ايضا عشرات
الالاف في شوارع العاصمه البلجيكيه بروكسل
في مظاهره غير مسبوقه كما جابت تظاهره
حاشده شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس وكل
هذه السيول البشريه خرجت للدعوه لايقاف ما
يتعرض له القطاع على الحدود اللبنانيه
اجرى وزير الدفاع العبري وافغان تقييما
للوضع في مستوطنه الجليل وتحدث مع عناصر
الجيش وقال جالنت ان مقامه لبنان تقترب من
ارتكاب خطا فادح وقد ينتهي الامر بسكان
بيروت الى نفس وضع القطاع في امريكا اقترح
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ان
تتخذ الولايات المتحده نهج عدم التدخل في
الصراع بين تل ابيب والفصائل خلال مقابله
مع شبكه يوني فيجن واوضح ترامب قائلا في
المقابله هناك حرب جاريه ومن المحتمل ان
عليك ان تدعها تاخذ مجراها لان الكثير من
الناس يفقدون حياتهم اوروبا تعترف حيره
غير مسبوقه ووضع صعب لا تستطيع اوكرانيا
الخروج منه ليزيد مفوض السياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزف بوريل كيف بلا
بقوله ان اوكرانيا لن تتمكن من هزيمه
روسيا في المستقبل المنظور مضيفا ان
التحدي الاخر الذي يواجه اوروبا هو الوضع
في الشرق الاوسط الذي كان نتيجه للفشل
السياسي والاخلاقي للمجتمع الدولي حسب
قوله ليخرج الملياردير الامريكي ايلون
ماسك داعيا الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي الى بدء مفاوضات مع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين والتوقف عن تدمير
الشباب الاوكراني في الخنادق على الجانب
الروسي يكل الجيش ولا يمل من استكمال
اهدافه واليوم ها هو الجيش الروسي يستهدف
منطقه كيف للمره الاولى بعد شهرين من
الهدوء النسبي وقال رئيس الاداره العسكريه
في كيف سيرجي
بوبكوف طويل دام 52 يوما جدد العدو هجماته
الصاروخيه على كييف لتنطلق صفارات الانذار
هناك في الجانب الدفاعي لروسيا هناك سلاح
افقد صواريخ كيف قدراتها حيث قال الجنرال
الاوكراني سيرجي كريفون وس في مقابله
تلفزيونيه ان روسيا ابتكرت وسائل قويه
للحرب الالكترونيه لدرجه ان الصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره التابعه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه تفقد فعاليتها واشتكى الضابط
من ضخامه قدره الاسلحه الروسيه واشار
كريفون وس في الوقت نفسه الى ان الروس
انفسهم يستخدمون الطائرات المسيره البحريه
لتدمير المعدات والقوى العامله للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه اما في الهجوم فطورت
روسيا جيلا جديدا من الصواريخ غير الموجهه
للطائرات والتي تجمع بين خصائص الخيرتين
في وقت واحد خارقه للخرسانه وتجزئه شديده
الانفجار حسب ما ذكرت شركه روستخ الحكوميه
ميدانيا عبر الصحفي الامريكي كليتن مورس
عن تفاجئه بنباء دحر ضباط رفيعي المستوى
في القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وذلك جراء
هجوم صاروخي خلال حفل توزيع جوائز لجنود
اللواء 128 في الجزء الذي تسيطر عليه كيف
من منطقه [__] روجيا فيما اعلن المكتب
التمثيلي لجمهوريه دونتسك الشعبيه في
المركز المشترك لمراقبه وتنسيق القضايا
المتعلقه بجرائم الحرب الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت اراضي الجمهوريه
26 مره خلال يوم واطلقت ما مجموعه 98
قذيفه مختلفه العيارات بالعوده الى واشنطن
قالت صحيفه بوليتيكو ان الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن يخطط لحديث صارم مع نظيره الصيني
شيجين بينغ حول روسيا وقضايا استراتيجيه
اخرى في العالم واضافت ان بايدن يعتبر
اللقاء فرصه اخيره للتاثير على الرئيس
الصيني لاعاده تشغيل التعاون قبل
الانتخابات في الولايات المتحده وبين هذا
وذا قالت كوريا الشماليه ان علاقاتها مع
روسيا ستظل قويه رغم تحذير امريكا من نقل
الاسلحه اليها واشار المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الكوريه الشماليه الى انه يجب
على امريكا ان تعتاد على الواقع الجديد
المتمثل في العلاقات متناميه بين بيونج
يانج وموسكو وفقا لوكاله انباء يونهاب
[موسيقى]
الكوريه
e